is a problem that is very hard for the
United States to solve it's not clear
How We Do solve that problem by problem
I mean sort of giving hegemony over the
world to a country that doesn't believe
anything really that we believe
it would be a massive change in the way
the worlds operate in the way that we in
the United States live I mean having
China in charge of the world would be
very different from what we have now
that's a huge concern a legitimate
concern I think and we're not
meaningfully dealing with it and I think
you often hear people on the right say
well that's because they're all taking
money from China yes that's true our
former Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright it was like a by the way
but got rich effectively making China's
case to the American Business Community
many others in our diplomatic War have
done the same that's a straight up
sellout Hollywood sells out the NBA
sells out they're controlled by the
Chinese government everyone knows that
but I think the deeper problem has
nothing to do with Commerce it just has
to do with the terrifying nature of this
threat